want to get obviously take a financial
angle on this we talked about oh save
that money yeah how many clearly how
much money people spend at bars or clubs
um
the
we talked about last episode how many
dates until a guy
buys you buy a guy dinner or take pay
for the date
um you meet a guy at the bar he's
obviously gonna be buying a round of
drinks do you ever buy
a round of drinks for a guy does that
ever happen you say i got this one is
that a thing that ladies do
i've done it for my friends but a guy
you're with like a guy like honey i got
this let me get like if i if you're with
a guy and he's with a buddy or so like
if i meet you at the club and you're
with amber and you're with them
at the club oh no just yes maybe we just
met or maybe like we know each other
round's on me 100 bucks done around for
everybody do you ever do that for a guy
no that's a hard no for him
if me and a guy have gone on a date and
we went to dinner and then we go and get
drinks i'll buy the drinks i like doing
that so you will do that
and we went to dinner and he covered a
good meal like and then we just said
not chipotle if he covered a big meal
and then we went to i like doing that as
an act of courtesy like what is that
walk me through that mentality of why a
woman now the guy just bought you dinner
why you would pay for drinks i want to
show that like i appreciate and value
your money and i don't need you to throw
it at me i'm an independent woman and i
make my own money and like just that
gesture men appreciate a lot and like
that buys me a lot of credit you know um
but for men that i just meet [ __ ] now
they're right because i also don't drink
at the club i'm not buying myself drinks
okay you know you do you have a strong
uh yeah no i mean if i just met you i'm
definitely not paying for your drink but
i've gone out and i've paid for my
friends like i have a lot of guy friends
or like my brother like guy friends is
different it's your homie yeah that's
what i'm saying yeah or you know if if
it's a guy that i'm seeing i'll pay i'll
tell you one story i um in miami
believe me i don't it's very rare for a
girl to be like adam don't worry i got
this one like never happens i was 10
years ago i went to uh
australia
and i was in sydney
and
me and i was with my buddy brendan and
we were there for new year's like we it
was the first year i was 27 years old 28
years old first year i ever made 100
grand or more like i was like i got so
much money like it was a big deal for me
at the time and i was like we're going
out australia he actually just got
laid off from the airlines company
recession he had like two free roundtree
tickets all over the world i caught a
deal with brendan he's like he's like i
got the plane first class australia i'm
like i'm paying for the hotels let's
doing it me and brendan are ripping it
up if you're watching brandon i love you
bro anyway we get to a bar we see these
two girls ladies what are you drinking
can we buy you a drink boom we're having
a drink we finish our drinks the the
girl goes i'll butcher this australian
actually she's like uh you bought the
first round next round's on us what are
you guys drinking i'm like am i being
[ __ ] punked right now what are you
talking about she goes yeah in australia
it's called shouts you got the first
shout we got the next shout and they
bought the drinks i was waiting for
ashton kutcher to walk in and be like
what is happening right now but just
because i was so preconditioned in miami
that the guys paid the guys paid the
guys pay that in australia the girls
it's like part of the culture for them
how much were the beers
i mean this is 10 years ago i don't know
whatever i'm just saying the drinks are
more expensive here too or whatever they
were 10 bucks a pound i buy drinks in
czech republic this [ __ ] is a dollar
okay let me buy for everybody
australia's is not a third world country
like they were real drinks
but
that is a thing guys paying for drinks
you know women don't have to in my
opinion by the way i did a poll on my
instagram i got to get the results
should a guy
always always always always pay
on the first date what do you think the
results were
they got on the first date should a guy
always pay
100 or is it original
no i don't i'm gonna check the results
right now oh your audience is highly
mail no no
probably two-thirds one-third
let me see those insights
two-thirds one-third are the responses
here should a guy always pay we'll see
about that